Hey guys, Dr. Burke here. I wanted to
answer a question that keeps coming up.
Will vegetable carbohydrates stop
ketosis? Okay, so it is true that
vegetables are carbohydrates. But the
question is, do they turn into sugar
fast or slow? There's a thing called the
glycemic index, and that is the rate or
which speed at which something actually
affects your blood sugars. I guarantee a
salad or maybe like a spinach salad with
celery when you eat that it is not going
to spike your insulin. Okay. So, some
people that start including more
vegetables, let's say they're doing the
Atkins diet, it's really high protein
and fat. And yes, the absence of
carbohydrates
do induce fat burning. But if you have
no uh vegetable types of carbohydrates,
what's going to happen? You're going to
get a lot of waste in your body and it's
called keto acidosis where your body's
pH starts going higher and higher and
higher. There's nothing to flesh that
out. So I want to read to you guidance
physiology what it says in page 927.
Okay. The effect of insulin lack on
causing a fatty liver. It's calling
causing the the lack of insulin, right?
when you keep insulin very low says it
causes a great increase in the amount of
stored triglyceride in the liver leading
to a very fatty liver. So in other
words, you got to be careful doing
ketosis because all this fat that's
being mobilized from your fat stores
from your stomach, it has to go through
the liver and go through your
bloodstream.
If you don't consume the vegetable,
you're going to end up with a fatty
liver. Okay? And that's defeats our
whole purpose. And sometimes when people
do this, they'll check their blood and
their cholesterol goes really, really
high because they're not eating the
vegetables to counteract that. Now, some
people are eating the wrong type of
vegetables. They're doing corn. Okay,
corn is not a vegetable in my viewpoint.
Or they're doing a lot of cruciferous,
but they're sensitive to it. They're not
digesting that, so they bloat. The
bloating will stop the weight loss.
Okay? So, just switch up your
vegetables. do something like a salad or
something like that. But the the
vegetable cleans and counteracts a lot
of the the fat burning that takes place
and it prevents the fat from
accumulating in your liver. The other
thing is that if you don't want to do
the vegetables, then where are you
getting your potassium from? From the
meat, from the fat, there's there's no
potassium in there. It's hardly any at
all. So, you need I mean a tremendous
amount.
So, and where are you getting your
magnesium? Where are you getting all
your vitamins and minerals? That's where
you get them from the vegetable family.
Okay? So, don't worry about vegetables
when you're doing ketosis. I think it's
essential. And I'm actually I put a
twist on this. It's like my version of
ketosis. You go ahead and do that and
you'll actually end up with a healthy
body. All right. Thanks for watching.